小沢度か恥だ皆さんが自爆ボタン知っていますでしょうもう
自爆ボタンとはそうですね何て言えばいいんだろうけど私の勝手なイメージだと悪役が
も負けるか来て負け確の時に前田智とも共に自爆だって分かってるようなボタンで自爆
張ったんだと思うんですけどもそれかいましたこちらで自爆ボタンまさか amazon
で
自爆ボタンなっていると思いませんでしょこれぞすごいとよく見ると対象年で15歳
以上だから結構そこそこの方向性じゃないとこれを使っていけない自爆ボタンですね
ジェニーと高校生超だったらいいのかと思うんですけどすごいすごいすごい先ほど
ちょっとしたストレス解消に最適です
ストレス回書籍しないで下さいじゃあ usb ハブとして難しいので普通に使い道は
るっで僕だ
でデスクに緊張感なさと呼びますそんな緊張はいかないですよどんなんでしょうマン
なくてアマゾンこうやって見てたら明らかに自爆ボタンちゃんと持って山と思って買っ
てみましたあげてみましょうぞ
うわぁうわなんかそれっと上甲はみなさんこれを持った以上で自爆をたんですよなんか
本格的なんですけどねぇーん
今わーうわーこはこのなんかをビナーれれば嫌だ
ちゃんと usb ハブとしても来てるんで後ろになると usb いう理屈もあり
ますねえめっちゃ加工部
恐山普通に1回私ずっと自爆してみますは強い声が入りますはい
はしました
が
わからないとどういうこと宇宙なんか電気的なものさせたんですけど何かたねー
でもで影入ってたんですよねこれだぜば今日の鍵がありました
やっぱそっかささみそんな簡単に自爆なんてできますよね手順なって多分一濡れ場
レバーをんっ
[音楽]
必要が来た来た来たじゃないいきましょうつきました次したつきました
えっ
あっああ
池尾そ言って言うんだ
あっはっは
うーんん
むさんなるほどでてが皆さん自爆ボタンあるとを知ってみたくなる説あると思うんです
よねこういうの見るとやっぱ
ず役者になると思うのでもっとこの唯一人が接続してなんかマジの自爆ブッダっぽい
感じにして勉強に雑魚ボタンを置いておくと人はどうするのか
今回を見ていきたいとおもいます僕は押します準備付
usb ハブがあるんで結構あさせるんですよねこういうくらいベチャっぽいなんか
やばいダメだろそれポケいるつないと言ったら相当政府に見えるんですよねすぎな元に
[音楽]
誰がしゃべったよなぁ
これか高はハードル赤い性があるところですよね
ダイナマイト作るかん
[音楽]
eme
そして完成しましたこんなに感じいかがでしょうかクレバリーナは一緒で約いろんな光
があるでも強く感じるんですよね
高緑青のいろんな花やその中に自爆評価がここにありますとと良いで結構リアリティを
増した気がしますね普通にパッドよりヤバイんで果たして自爆スイッチがあったら人は
をしてしまうのか惜しまないのかそれともどうなるのかさっそくいろんなさん
思って聴いて実験してみよう外交
[音楽]
やっほー
割れず無事完了ちょっと怖い方の質ために部屋の照明をめざ草赤にしますか次
ちょっと入ってくるっともうこんな状況になっております
そしてここに自爆ボタン
おいております私の予想なんだったも本来危険な状態だと自爆する必要はねェんだけど
もなぜか押さなきゃいけないような空気になって重爆ボタンを押してしまうと思うん
ですよ
それで早速人間の生体に調べていきましょう
[音楽]
えっ
うん
[音楽]
me
うわぁ爆弾だ
nome
これでどっちこれをした何の母
がある
[音楽]
ああああああ
ああああああああああああ
待って待って
nao
[音楽]
me
全然ですっ
ani
me
[音楽]
烏山のねー
me
goo
あああああん
[音楽]
4件で理由しれん
amaran
me
貼っじゃ多分読みだわー
ダークブラウンが入って入って
dj baku なんじゃこれ
ホラー
うー待っていっ
あっは
[音楽]
bl